non
michael chang qualifié pour la finale de
roland garros
suspense dans l'autre match et baer &
decker au couteau deng xiao ping à son
tour et apparaît en chine c'est la
victoire des ultra conservateurs et de
la répression congrès de montréal sur le
sida on reparle d'un vaccin bilan du
congrès avec le docteur rosenbaum en
direct du canada dans ce journal
la voiture propre c'est pour demain en
europe les 12 des sites des normes
draconiennes 10 92 pour les petites
voitures
bajeux spéciale europe comme chaque
vendredi coup de caméra sur un candidat
pas comme les autres claude lelouch sur
la liste simone veil
bonsoir et tout d'abord tout de suite le
tournoi de roland garros incertitude
totale dans la première demi finale
michael chang a battu chesnau coffre
nous y reviendrons à la fin de ce
journal
mais dans la deuxième demi-finale stefan
edberg et boris becker se livrent à un
combat de titans ils sont deux sets
partout alors jean ma mère tout de suite
où en est-on porte d'auteuil
eh bien écoutez en et se retrouve tout
lisse sur le central où boris becker au
service vient de je dirais remporté une
balle de débreak il a il avait
effectivement remporté dès le début de
cette cinquième manche
il avait pris le service de bergues et
là il y avait un avantage pour stefan
edberg il vient de sauver regarder la
joie de de becker becker qui est revenu
dans ce match au cours du troisième et
du quatrième set il a les yeux qui lui
sortent parfois de la tête
il ya une tension extrême qui règne ici
sur ce central c'est assez fabuleux il
faut le dire à un moment et bergen le
match dans sa raquette
il a laissé passer l'occasion becker en
a profité pour revenir et là c'est
vraiment un duel vous l'avez dit de
titan c'est vraiment un duel de géants
il ya vraiment deux grands joueurs en ce
moment sur le central est donc pour
l'instant les kerr essaye de prendre
de marquer le point pour mener 2-0 dans
cette cinquième manche a tout de suite
jean on vous retrouve dans ce journal
pour avoir du nouveau sur ce match la
chine maintenant en chine l'espoir
s'éloigne pour tout un peuple qui
réclamaient la démocratie
après une longue période de silence deng
xiao ping l'homme fort est réapparu à la
télévision plus fort que jamais
semble-t-il à 84 ans une manière de
justifier la répression
une manière aussi de confirmer que ce
sont bien les ultras les conservateurs
qui ont gagné la bataille de pékin alors
comme chaque jour nous retrouvons tout
de suite au téléphone l'un de nos
envoyés spéciaux
bruno le dresse la réapparition en
public numéro un chinois c'est 24 joseph
dans une semaine de rumeurs sur son
éventuel décès confirme bien que les
aborde une nouvelle étape de la
normalisation
face à un parterre de généraux en grand
uniforme dengue était entouré des
principaux membres du conseil des sages
au sein duquel siège la plupart des
éléments de la vieille garde tissu de la
révolution à sa droite des bugs au
premier ministre à la gauche
les dernières l'ancien président de la
république les purs les vainqueurs exilé
à l'extrémité de la table ces deux
derniers libérons 6 et perdant
paraissent hermanis mon audience mais le
message est destiné au peuple chinois
il approuve totalement l'action
militaire du week end dernier contre ce
qu'il appelle des rebelles favorables au
capitalisme et désireux de créer une
république bourgeoise fait observer une
minute de silence en l'honneur des
soldats tués lors des affrontements
la chine entre aujourd'hui dans l'ère du
matraquage idéologique et de la
répression
ainsi nombre nous le disait la
normalisation s'installe en chine six
jours après le début de l'écrasement de
la révolte nous envoyés spéciaux à pékin
bruno carette christian euros et bruno
le dreff ont pu le constater
voici le reportage qu'ils nous ont fait
parvenir il y à quelques minutes la
gymnastique matinale scène
traditionnelle de la chine aujourd'hui
indices d'une reprise de la vie
archer rare depuis le début de la
semaine était ce matin à nouveau tous
ouverts les prix sont restés stables
preuve que l'approvisionnement se fait
sans problème les administrations les
magasins d'état restent fermés nouvelles
formes de résistance passive les
pikinois prennent simplement du danger
qu'il y aurait à circuler pour ne pas se
rendre au travail
pourtant les échoppes privé les petits
restaurants tout ce qui relève de
l'économie nonne étatisée est à nouveau
ouvert pourtant l'armée est toujours
présent là bas quelques centaines de
mètres au bout de cette avenue se trouve
un millier de militaires qui compte pour
l'une des portes d'entrée au centre
regardez fait d'armé qui fait toujours
corps étranger d'information de la ville
ainsi plus de 400 français ont quitté la
capitale chinoise ce matin un départ
largement conseillé par l'ambassade de
france l'embarquement s'est déroulé
tranquillement saint panique même si
certains souhaitaient depuis plusieurs
jours rentré la france
ces emprunts
mais de nombreux français regretté de
devoir quitter la chine
beaucoup d'entre eux les moments les
plus durs sont passés également
impression c'est vraiment danger puisque
pékin sont quand même assez calme
là où j'habite
inquiet des larmes
il est encore d
des tirs de pistolets mitrailleurs ces
données
des charentes à ce prix mais
quand on vient et emploi
les soldats sont sur le bord de la route
mais
c'est vrai qu'il ressent une certaine
tension
mais c'est pendant aujourd'hui de
nombreux chinois regrette de voir les
étrangers partir ils craignent désormais
de se trouver seul sans témoins pour le
protéger face à la répression qui
commencent à s'organiser normalisation
répression aussi délation le pouvoir
emploi tous les moyens pour écraser la
révolte des étudiants et du peuple
écoutez par exemple comment le
commentateur de la télévision appel
depuis hier les habitants a dénoncé les
fameux fauteurs de trouble ont séché
trombone tuba ou bien aux lions et ont
dû lâcher
josh hennessy jaune luis lopez julien
courbet on n'a pas trop de soucis à
abattre la pandémie marché j'ai voilà ça
c'est la propagande chinoise qu'on
entend la télévision de pékin
avec enfin cette information
conditionnelle ou en demande le leader
des étudiants chinois auraient été tuées
dans les affrontements de ces derniers
jours montrent donc c'est l'homme que
vous voyez à droite sur cet écran un
homme souriant que nos envoyés spéciaux
avait pu rencontrer à pékin il ya
quelques semaines il était animé d'un
fol espoir de démocratie et de
changement il aurait été tué donc ces
jours derniers une nouvelle information
dramatiques sur ces heures difficiles
de la chine accor en pologne entre le
pouvoir et l'opposition solidarité
accepté de repêcher la liste nationale
la liste du parti qui pourtant avait été
largement battu au premier tour
un comble c'est l'opposition qui
maintenant fait de larges concessions au
pouvoir polonais un efforts des
européens pour lutter contre la
pollution à partir de 1992 c'est à dire
très bientôt les petites voitures
devront être moins polluantes
les 12 pays lassés se sont mis d'accord
tout à l'heure pour fixer des normes
draconiennes alors cela veut dire
multiplication des pots catalytiques et
puis aussi quelques problèmes pour les
constructeurs français gérard leclerc
c'est le grand vainqueur de l'accord
européen à partir de 1992 le pot
catalytique devra équiper toutes les
voitures de moins de 14 centimètres
cubes l'équivalent des recettes coup
deux cent cinq à huit jours des
élections européennes est sous la
pression des écologistes
les ministres des 12 ont avancé de
quelques mois l'adoption des normes en
vigueur aux états unis et qui impose le
pot catalytique
d'ici là les gouvernements pourront
consentir des incitations fiscales aux
acheteurs de voitures propres
ce que réclamait l'allemagne et les pays
bas mais que la france jusque là refusé
chez les constructeurs français renault
affiche la sérénité et utilisent déjà la
voiture propre dans ses publicités
c'est au contraire une défaite pour le
président de peugeot jacques calvet qui
sait jusqu'au bout opposé à une
technique qu'il juge dépassé et qui
augmentera d'environ 5%
le prix des petites voitures il reste à
la france a développé les stations
vendant de l'essence sans plomb une sur
dix actuellement éventuellement à
recourir elle aussi aux incitations
fiscales ce que réclame ce soir les
écologistes et puis j'ajoute que les
européens se sont aussi engagés à
protéger les éléphants et oui c'est un
sujet important
il prépare des mesures pour interdire
l'importation de l'ivoire dans tous les
pays de la cee
le congrès de montréal sur le sida avec
cette information qui a surpris tous les
participants le professeur américain
salque celui là même qui avait mise au
point dans les années 50 un vaccin
contre la polio le professeur sall
qu'aurait obtenus des résultats à propos
d'un vaccin anti sida
nous allons y revenir mais d'abord le
congrès lui même il y avait plus de
10000 participants participants à
montréal pardon pendant toute la semaine
donc des spécialistes du monde entier
étaient réunies et il est temps je crois
maintenant de faire le bilan alors avec
nous en direct de montréal le professeur
rozenbaum bon le docteur rosenbaum
bonsoir docteur montréal était un autre
congrès très très médiatisée on l'a vu
il y avait plus de dix mille chercheurs
du monde entier
est ce que votre avis à un congrès comme
ça sert vraiment à quelque chose
écoutez les congrès servent pour nous
rencontrer pour rencontrer des
spécialistes travaillent sur le même
domaine mais dans des champs parallèle
et bien entendu vous n'attendez pas les
congrès pour nous parler ou pour
communiquer mais là nous sommes tous
ensemble et pouvoir échanger le maximum
la formation alors aujourd'hui dans ce
sens ça se fait ça ces docteurs
rosenbaum au cours de ce congrès on a
fait pas mal de bilan notamment et en
particulier sur la tête et ce médicament
qui avait donné au début des résultats
assez prometteur et on a l'impression
que maintenant les chercheurs sont un
peu déçus par l'ase aide t moi je crois
pas qu'on soit vraiment déçu je crois
que ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé c'est les
chiffres les derniers six couples fret
sur l'espérance de vie des malades et
entrons nous a montré que jusqu'à 19
centres est adam 86 et depuis 86
l'espérance de vie des malades étaient
avait augmenté de 200%
ce qui est énorme et dans cette
augmentation une part peut être
rapportée à la sainteté et puis une
autre part aux autres optique
en particulier le traitement des
infections qui ont fait ces dernières
années un progrès énorme
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire
qu'il ya des traitements contre le sida
c'est quelque chose qu'on a de très
important un congrès qui glace était un
congrès qui donne de l'espoir je disais
oui ceci forlan ne peuvent que donner de
l'espoir
bien entendu tout n'est pas réglé pour
l'accepter il n'a pas réglé tous les
problèmes c'est vrai mais ces progrès la
sont indiscutables je crois qu'il faut
les les enregistrer la ligue dans le
sens d'un meilleur contrôle de la
maladie comme on nous l'a montré
alors il ya ce fameux vaccin anti sida
dont on a parlé dont je viens de parler
en en ce moment je rappelle tout de même
qu'il a été annoncé par le docteur
salque qui était l'un des pères du
vaccin anti polio c'est donc quelqu'un
de sérieux qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui là je crois encore qu'il ya des
choses très prématuré il ya eu sur les
vaccinations un très grand nombre de
données accumulées
j'irai sur les essais de vaccination
mais les données qui ont été fournis par
monsieur salle qui ne permettent pas de
dire qu'un vaccin est disponible sur
tous et n'est pas ce qu'il faudra
retenir mais quelques-uns pas et ont
répondu je dirais favorablement à des
stratégies vaccinales
il ya encore un pas de vis de la
vaccination je ne faudra pas retenir que
c'est quelque chose de gagner à ce
niveau là
quoi qu'on a plus avancés dans le
contexte traitement que dans celui de la
vaccination
merci docteur rosendo merci pour toutes
ces explications sur ce congrès de
montréal sur le sida voilà tout de suite
un break comme on dit si adam ce journal
pour retourner immédiatement roland
garros ce genre ma mère où en est-on à
roland garros et tout à l'heure vous
nous aviez laissé becker avait un peul
avantage alors becker finalement a perdu
son service tout à l'heure ce qui fait
que pour l'instant et bien cette aide
berg qui mène 2 jeux à 1 dans cette
cinquième manche et nous arrivons à un
moment très important puisque hedberg
al'avantage sur le service de becker
c'est à dire que la becker peut servir
s'il perd son service ed baird mènerait
3 juin c'est sans doute le tournant
alors vers un gars très important
premier service sur la ligne
vous avez entendu le petit sifflement
avantage est berd dont
et voilà et voila fr vient donc de
prendre le service de boris becker et
mène maintenant 3 juin dans la cinquième
manche et va servir pour 4 jose a dans
la foulée c'est peut-être le tournant le
tournant de ces de cette grande
rencontre
becker et bien être jean luneau cendres
montrent à leur bien sûr tout à l'heure
dans ce journal merci la politique
maintenant avec les élections
européennes j - 9
nous continuons à suivre les leaders en
campagne bien sûr ce soir
valéry giscard d'estaing et jacques
chirac ils sont allés ensemble à lyon
rencontré michel noir et alain carignon
décidément les rénovateurs de
l'opposition sont très courtisés
olivier lerner bonjour vous saviez rendu
hommage simon grayson à venir lorsque
j'étais venu ici aujourd'hui vous allez
sans doute axé votre discours côté
européen hors du bitume à la faire votre
discours aujourd'hui vous avez du mal à
réaliser votre maison rouge une plume
pied pas leur temps qu'il faut
c'est pas l'heure était plus facile pour
vous de recevoir une belle
qu'aujourd'hui giscard d'estaing vous
rendre au moment d'aller parler des
rénovateurs aujourd'hui ce que vous avez
osé non michel noir n'a pas osé
attendez nous at il glissé nous en
reparlerons devant jacques chirac et
valéry giscard d'estaing à l'hôtel de
ville de lyon
le rénovateur michel noir n'a pas trouvé
mieux que d'insister sur un mot tout à
la fois une ville de fidélité et
d'audace depuis des siècles
elle n'a pas changé comme les temps
présents en témoigne en témoigneront je
souhaite que le 18 juin prochain les
lyonnaises et les lyonnais fidèles à
leur tradition de ville capitale de
ville libérale et de villes européennes
manifestent leur volonté de faire du 18
juin 1989
un jour deux fondations de la future
union de l'europe
michel noir s'inclinent et applaudit des
deux mains mais dès dimanche rénovateurs
et réformateurs se retrouveront sur les
hauteurs de grenoble pour une nouvelle
mise au point comme chaque vendredi
maintenant notre page spéciale
européenne dans la perspective bien sûr
des élections qui ont lieu je vous le
rappelle le 18 juin à commencer par la
suite de notre enquête sur ces hommes et
ces femmes non spécialistes de la
politique qui se lancent dans la bagarre
électorale exemple claude autant-lara
pour l'extrême droite le professeur
schwartzenberg pour lés socialistes ou
encore jeannou lacaze pour la liste
giscard et bien ce soir un coup de
caméra sur un cinéaste claude lelouch se
présente sur la liste de simone veil
véronique saint olive et claude barnier
claude lelouch tourner dans le port de
trouville les premiers plans de son
prochain film le 30e il ya des jours
c'est le titre du film c'est aussi
lellouche qui a 51 ans plongeant
politique
pas pour la politique mais pour simone
veil tête de la liste centriste
elle l'a elle à la tendresse des vraies
femmes et à la la force des hommes ce
qui est l'armé absolue quoi
je crois qu'elle elle pense vraiment aux
autres je pense vraiment aux autres là
elle a un parcours pour les autres une
générosité qui est là et c'est ça qui me
touche je suis plus touchées par
l'aspect ma part sont l'aspect politique
ou par ses choix politiques
le metteur en scène gâté a rencontré la
femme politique la plus populaire de
france
ce n'est pas une histoire d'amour mais
c'est quand même une aventure celle de
l'europe et de l'audiovisuel dans
laquelle lellouche voudrait bien jouer
un petit rôle
les 13e sur la lune son chiffre fétiche
qui lui laisse peu de chances d'être élu
mais les scénarios le loup ou chien ont
parfois des rebonds bizarres l'oeil de
sa caméra transperce image publique de
simone veil et lellouche
en fait le personnage d'un scénario
imaginaire d'un personnage à suspense
c'est un personnage qui est qui mène un
combat permanent
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est dans
l'action alors on se sentira pas de
temps mort spectateurs ne s'ennuieront
pas une seule seconde
reporter de sa propre fiction claude
lelouch mais l'europe en scène dans sa
tête il filme du bout des yeux les
acteurs qui veulent la faire il ya des
jours comme ça où l' aventure c'est la
politique
l'europe suit la grande nouveauté l'une
des grandes nouveautés 92 ce sera la
possibilité de travailler dans tous les
pays d'europe
bien sûr cela existe déjà par exemple
cette entreprise de tuyaux à
sully-sur-loire les salariés sont
français mais le patron et allemand
christophe martet et et christian hottin
reportage
friedrich sculpteur peut être satisfait
son entreprise tourneront pour cet homme
originaire de westphalie tout a commencé
il y à 25 ans par un coup de coeur j'ai
été envoyé par un oscar le monde voilà
que je travaillais déjà depuis quelques
années mais j'ai souhaité le travail et
en france c'est mon désir pourquoi
j'avais fait beaucoup de voyages par
auto stop dans ma jeunesse en france et
j'étais travaillé pendant trois semaines
si tu es dans les landes
et c'est ça qui m'a premiers tees sur
l'entreprise
elle joue sur les deux tableaux ici un
patron allemand c'est encore la garantie
d'une bonne image de marque et pour le
patron les salariés français supporte
bien la comparaison je prends les
français sont différemment des cyprès
nez
ça ressemble pas en premier lieu ils
respectent pas peut-être tous les rouges
mais pas vu hygiène de vie et
de travail ils sont peut-être autant que
nantes
généralement chaque fois que j'annonçais
où j'ai informé mes interlocuteurs que
mon patron était allemand je sentais
tout de suite un frisson de sécurité
passaient dans l'assistance pionnier de
l'europe sans frontières très riche
culture n'est pourtant toujours pas
considéré comme un patron à part entière
je travaille pour la chambre de commerce
comme il se doit et avec plaisir est là
mais je peux toujours pas ni élire les
représentants du genre de commerce ni
être vu
pourquoi ce sont les petites choses qui
ont des vrais moments si rigueur
l'europe peut mieux faire
il lui reste à peine quatre ans pour
être tout à fait européenne le procès de
la branche lyonnaise d'action directe
suite c'est un procès qui dure depuis la
mi mai maintenant vous savez cette fois
les accusés devaient répondre d' à auld
qui avait finalement coûté la vie au
général de gendarmerie dit delfosse
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan en se rendant la dix neuvième
audience de leur procès les membres
d'action directe se doutait qu'ils
allaient assister à une bataille
d'experts en balistique
la suite leur a donné raison car pour le
hold up de mars 81 capes deux armes
totalement différente sont présentées
comme étant celles qui a tué le général
guy delfosse
cet après midi à la barre de
spécialistes en balistique certifie que
l'arm découverte dans la cage
stéphanoise d'action directe et celle du
crime puis devant olivier un frérot
attentif deux autres experts des
demandes
monsieur le président il n'y a pas le
moindre doute larmes qui a tué delfosse
c'est la seconde 1 38 spécial et les
deux premiers experts de faire amende
honorable devant la cour nous n'avons
jamais eu la seconde arme en main
sinon nous aurions abouti aux mêmes
conclusions que nos confrères d erreur
sur des expertises c'est grave quand
cela pèse lourd dans un dossier rétorque
un avocat et le juge d'instruction de
répondre il faut peut-être relativiser
l'importance des expertises en deux
jours de débats on aura très peu parlé
de la personnalité de guy delfosse
l'homme qui a voulu s'interposer dans ce
hold up sa fille aura tout juste eu le
temps de dire aujourd'hui souligne forme
il y avait un homme qui aurait agi de la
même façon s'il avait été en civil
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
importantes de ce vendredi à commencer
par la prise de position de monseigneur
de courtrai à propos de la sphère
touvier l'archevêque de lyon a décidé
d'ouvrir les archives de son archevêché
pour les besoins de l'enquêté
établir une fois pour toute la vérité
historique à la fois sur la conduite de
paul touvier pendant l'occupation et sur
le rôle de l'église dans sa fuite
c'est le but de la proposition faite par
l'archevêque de lyon selon monseigneur
daucourt trek l'arrestation du milicien
à réveiller les passions les meilleurs
comme la soif de vérité et de justice
mais aussi les pires des inévitables
défoulement anticléricaux recherché pour
crimes contre l'humanité
paul soulié a été arrêté dans un couvent
du vieux nice ce qui avait soulevé des
polémiques sur la nature du droit
d'asile
plus de responsabilités pour les
policiers en tenue ils pourront recevoir
des plaintes recueillir des témoignages
constater les tripes velicou
contravention désormais agent de police
judiciaire les gardiens de la paix
reçoivent les mêmes prérogatives que les
gendarmes
cette réforme c'est parti d'un plan pour
améliorer l'ensemble du service public
de la police parmi les effets attendus
un meilleur accueil dans les
commissariats où l'on pourra déposer
plainte à tout faire et un traitement
plus rapide les affaires courantes
pas de bus ni tramway à lille
aujourd'hui tous les contrôleurs et
conducteurs s'étaient mis en grève pour
protester contre l'insécurité qui règne
dans les transports en commun lillois
plusieurs chauffeurs bulls ont été
attaquées ces derniers mois seuls les
deux lignes de métro en fonctionner un
métro il est vrai entièrement
automatique sans conducteur toutes ces
informations
isabelle de lyon en ce moment même c'est
le salon du bourget vous le savez c'est
le rendez vous obligé des professionnels
de l'aviation mais aussi des aviateurs
amateurs il y en france de plus en plus
de fana de l'aviation dont qu'ils
apprennent à piloter et pour cela il y a
plusieurs méthodes
c'est souvent d'ailleurs une question de
moyens vous allez le voir alors nos
spécialistes patrice pollet et patrick
esther se sont mis aux commandes pour
tester ces écoles de pilotage reportage
ici c'est la bonne vieille méthode
classique qui est enseigné
exceptionnellement avant mon premier vol
ne seront épargnés le nettoyage de
l'avion à la main et le balayage du
hangar pour le décollage j'ai la main
sur les commandes bien sûr mais je ne
pilote pas c'est un peu plus tard que je
vais effectuer mon premier virage sur la
droite un lien d'ailleurs beaucoup trop
serré
pas aussi serré que celui de
l'instructeur qui me montre les limites
de possibilités de l'avion nous tombons
ici à plus de 200 kilomètres heure
après quarante cinq heures de vol mon
brevet m'aura coûté environ 27 mille
francs au club
le niveau d'instruction est excellent et
l'ambiance plutôt sympathique
mais vous n'êtes pas forcément
intéressés par le balayage les hangars
les samedis et dimanches
disposer de pourquoi de temps
mais prendre des cours sur rendez-vous
dans des écoles professionnelles de
pilotage la prépa c'est le prouver en un
temps record à toussus-le-noble à la
socata chaque leçon commence par un
audiovisuel de 25 minutes
un instructeur professionnel confirmé
prépare ensuite le vol avec l'élève
pendant ce temps là on vous sort l'avion
du hangar dès le premier cours vous
démarrez le moteur et vous décollez
vous-même l'appareil sous le contrôle de
l'instructeur l'avion est toujours très
récent il est de plus équipé
d'instruments de vol permettant de
véritablement apprendre à voyager entre
la douzaine d'escales que l'école
possède en france
une aubaine pour les hommes d'affaires
les difficultés qu'on rencontre sur les
lignes régulières ou les trains sont
très difficiles pour aller dans les
régions en france
j'ai donc passé ma ville ma licence de
pilote très rapidement cinq mois ce qui
me permet de me déplacer sans contrainte
d'horaires sur toute la france très
efficace ces stages de 50 heures de vol
dont qu'un défaut le prix 50 mille
francs pour le brevet de pilote
cyclisme avec laurent fignon qui
attaquent dans le giro il est maillot
rose vous le savez bien aujourd'hui
laurent fignon a remporté la 20e étape
consolidant ainsi sa première place au
classement général
il a battu au sprint ses principaux
rivaux au classement général justement
36 maroteaux laurent fignon qui part à
deux kilomètres de l'arrivée
c'est fillon qui s'est refait une santé
après les problèmes de ces derniers
jours en fait le leader du giro veut
montrer à ses principaux adversaires
qu'il entend rester le maître mais au
cours des 220 kilomètres de cette 20e
étape disputée entre google a hélas
pedia les hommes forts du peloton décide
de ne pas laisser partir le français
fignon est repris c'est ensuite un petit
groupe qui se détache à nouveau et parmi
ces nouveaux fuyards on retrouve laurent
fignon
laurent fignon qui impose sa puissance
et sa fraîcheur physique en fin de
course
fignon à gauche de l'écran remporte
l'étape en poche 10 secondes de
bonification et précède désormais
l'italien di pony d'une minute et 26
secondes et l'amérique à ramstein d'une
minute trente et une secondes le tout à
deux jours de l'arrivée mais attention
demain étapes de montagne et
après-demain dernière étape à florence
contre
montre individuel et roland garros tout
de suite nous allons y retourner puisque
effectivement edberg et becker dans la
deuxième demi finale sont au cinquième
set alors au couteau bien sûr j'en rêve
pour manger mais bon le break a été fait
par stefan edberg qui mène maintenant 5
jeux à 2 dans la cinquième manche alors
comme c'est le temps mort je vous
propose de revenir sur l'autre
demi-finale qui s'est disputé cet après
midi avec l'américain michael chang jean
pradinas de nous envoyer des images tout
de suite michael chang qui réalisera
tout de même l'exploit d'être le plus
jeune finaliste de roland garros il ne
sera peut-être pas le plus gros gabarit
mais en tout cas ça sera sûrement le
plus accrocheur des journaux des plus
des joueurs que l'on ait vu aujourd'hui
à roland garros cette année
malgré son jeune âge michael chang a
montré une faculté d'adaptation et
surtout un mental extraordinaire même en
perdition par moments sur un point
important il a toujours trouvé l'énergie
nécessaire pour sauver les situations
les plus périlleuses
le bluff peut-être sur le plan physique
car les deux joueurs sont restés 14 sur
le court mais suffisant pour
déstabiliser l'adversaire
aujourd'hui michael chang a joué juste
heureusement pour lui parce que son
adversaire a couru après le bon rythme
et aussi après le score et il a laissé
passer trop d'occasions
ce que tu chantes lui n'a jamais omis de
faire et toujours avec juste ce qu'il
faut de cinéma il est l'acteur le
palmarès de roland-garros mais ce soir
buts et même les parieurs les plus
aguerris alors hervé je vous propose de
revenir maintenant sur le central donc
et berck semble avoir pris la mesure de
becker villa mesure de becker becker est
au service et et mener maintenant 0 15
sur son service alors cela fera ou 5
jeux à 3 6 b qui remporte son service ou
bien match pour hedberg s'il prenait le
service de becker je vous propose de
nous retrouver peut-être dans dans
quatre cinq minutes avec les noms gens
parce qu'ils feront qu un conte termine
ce journal alors simplement on va
regarder la première balle de becker et
puis je crois malheureusement que nous
puissions continuer si l égalité dignité
cascades continuer ce téléphone je me
rends peine
ok c'est extraordinaire ce qui se passe
en ce moment sur le central vraiment
parce que chacun son tour les joueurs
sont sortis ou entrer dans la partie
becker a en fin de quatrième en début de
cinquième set semblait en main et puis
et puis petit à petit la lâcher pied
il faut dire que hedberg a un mental une
lucidité assez extraordinaire alors
bonne nouvelle jean on continue par fait
qu'un franc
tiens tant la lpr qui est à deux points
du march becker accuse le coup quand
même il a pris il faut le dire deux
trois coups au moral sur des balles
qu'être berg est allé chercher on se
demande vraiment comment être baer qui
sent la fin de la partie à sa portée il
essaie de se décontracter en sautillant
sur ses jambes ce qu'il fait assez
régulièrement il est très très concentré
il a quand même encore verso plénière et
il est toujours aussi bon à la volée
même si aujourd'hui n'a fait aussi
déterminant à la fois aux services à la
fois la volée comme une poule est
notamment sur les surfaces rapides comme
à wimbledon qui est plus son jardin
c'était combien temps qui joue gens il y
a maintenant pratiquement quatre heures
qui sont sur le court eux aussi et
pourtant ils ont encore des raisons
encore beaucoup de réserve il faut dire
que là dans ce cinquième set c'est
vraiment celui je dirais qui prend le
filet pour impressionner son adversaire
qui fait le point on sent quand même la
fatigue qui gagnent les deux joueurs il
ya il ya eu moins je dirais de d'égalité
dans chaque jeu puis s'assoit sur leur
visage effectivement mais on comprendra
yagg
40 40 30
quelle tension et bergues à l'été passé
quand même quelques occasions notamment
dans le quatrième set mais là il s'est
bien repris
gardez les yeux de becker quelle volonté
de vaincre égalité à 42 se mord les
doigts un peu decker de fautes directes
qui leur qu'il a trop souvent fait les
zones ray est de nouveau et bergues à
deux points du mat de nouveaux repères
qu'à deux points du match formidable
suspense en direct
première balle de max bw stefan edberg
merci en tout cas la chaîne de nous
laisser la possibilité de finir que
cette rampe en suis vraiment aura été
l'une des plus belles parties de tennis
de toute façon de tout ce roland-garros
au fort goût de la finale qu'elle
officie n'a sans doute la plus belle
ah oui vraiment du grand tennis l'a
cette fois ci il n'y a pas d'histoire de
bluff de fatigue de coupure de pluie
c'est vraiment du grand tennis à l'état
pur
à becker a l'air fatigué un peu becker
est fatigué il a eu un pourcentage de
première balle assez faible ce qui l'a
handicapée tout au long de l'après midi
toute façon ça c'est certain
le match en direct
merci et bravo stefan edberg en finale
donc contre michael jambes il y à une
seule chose dans commune je dirais avec
le tournant de roland garros de l'année
dernière c'est qu'il y aura quand même
au suédois en finale c'était bilan d'air
le tenant du titre il a été sorti il ya
deux jours ce sera est verte qui va le
remplacer
de toute façon ça sera un gros joueur
qui sera en finale
espérons le nous assisterons à une
grande finale même si on est un peu dans
l'inconnu avec michael chang
de toute façon il y aura au moins un
grand c'est sûr c'est stéphane hébert
sur le central de roland garros dimanche
après midi à partir de 15h sur antenne 2
en direct à ne pas manquer merci jean et
merci nous avoir fait vivre en direct
ses derniers moments donc en direct
formidable la victoire d'eads berck dans
la deuxième demi-finale et berck qui
donc grand contreras chang en finale
avant lé hangar hausse dimanche voit la
fin du journal tout de suite vous avez
rendez vous avec la météo pour les
prévisions de ce week-end qui sont pas
mauvaises c'est laurent cabrol qui va
vous les donner alors les rendez vous de
la soirée apostrophes de bernard pivot
sur le thème de l'humour et de
l'insolence ne le manquez pas et puis
dernier journal c'est henri sannier aux
alentours de 23h pour le week-end comme
d'habitude pour trouver la grande équipe
daniel bilalian betty dureau philippe
gassot
ce sont eux qui vous tiendrons au
courant de l'actualité bonne soirée sur
antenne 2 bon week end
à